the labor market is incredibly strong it
might seem like fed chairman Jerome
Powell's view of the labor market
doesn't jive with the leg off after
layoff after layoff that has plagued to
the tech industry however he's right at
least according to the labor
Department's recent jobs reports
employers added over 260 000 new
positions in November the 23rd month in
a row the economy has added them and
unemployment is under four percent near
the lowest on record so this is a great
Labor Market in in that sense there's
this huge disconnect you're hearing
about companies like Amazon Twitter
doordash layoff workers and it feels
like we're we're in the middle of a
recession here's why those big headlines
aren't in sync with the overall job
market
first some of the recent layoffs aren't
yet reflected in the data for example
about 1.4 million people were laid off
or discharged from their jobs in
November but that number may not include
the entire month some of this data does
come with a lag for example some
companies may have announced these
layoffs too late in the month for them
to be captured in the data for example
doordash's cuts on November 30th weren't
reflected in the report neither were
Amazon's on the 16th or carvanas on the
18th also the labor department counts
the layoffs themselves not the
announcements companies may be saying
that they're going to tighten their
belts and lay people off but they simply
haven't made those cuts quite yet so
that can lead to that lag the delay
might be part of the reason the
unemployment rate has stayed near an
all-time 50-year low 3.7 percent but
there's more to it the jobs Market is in
a really really weird place right now
and there's this historic gap between
the number of workers looking for
employment and the number of jobs out
there that Gap is partly driven by a
shrinking Workforce the labor force
participation rate the number of people
out there looking for jobs and wanting
to have a job is historically low and
actually ticked down in November one
reason why fewer people are looking is
that Millions left the workforce during
the covid-19 pandemic starting in 2020
roughly 2.6 million retired early and
more people retired in 2020 than had in
the previous eight years others left for
reasons like lack of child care now
there's about 1.7 job openings for every
person looking for work so what we're
seeing is intense competition for
workers right now because you have this
gap between the number of jobs out there
and the number of people looking for
jobs and that helps add to this low
unemployment rate while covid is
affecting unemployment Tech layoffs
aren't big enough to register
but data quirks are just one factor
another is that the job cuts are
proportionally smaller than the
headlines might have you believe
looking at the numbers Amazon and meta
announced layoffs of about 10
000 and 11 000 each
snap said they'd cut 1 200 jobs Shopify
cited 1000 and Netflix estimated 300. in
the entire sector about 50 000 job Cuts
were announced in November
to put that into perspective there are
more than 150 million people working in
the U.S the entire tech industry is just
three percent of the whole
you'd think it'd be companies in the S P
500 the mega cap company's driving job
growth in the US but in fact it's the
small businesses driving more of the job
growth companies within the S P 500 make
up just 19 of employment in the U.S
to be sure Tech layoffs did count for a
large proportion of November's job cuts
and this year there were more than any
year since 2002.
so these tech companies are Market
leaders they are some of the biggest
companies in the U.S if not the entire
world and they also Loom large over the
public Consciousness I mean think about
the phones that we use the computers
that we use where we online shop you
know they are leaders in so many
different ways however they just don't
make up as big of a part of the labor
market as we think other sectors that
lost jobs include retail and
transportation and warehousing but it's
still unclear whether layoffs will
continue in those sectors
economists expect that additional
interest rate hikes from the FED May
trigger more widespread layoffs
so the tech industry is facing one of
its biggest tests and one of its biggest
downturns of the past decade as the
Slowdown continues we very well could
see more Tech layoffs ahead
and as inflation remains High additional
layoffs will depend on how the job
market reacts to Fed policy